[Music]
what if I told you there are trillions
of tiny bacteria all around you it's
true microorganisms called bacteria were
some of the first life-forms to appear
on earth though they consist of only a
single cell their total biomass is
greater than that of all plants and
animals combined
and they live virtually everywhere on
the ground in the water on your kitchen
table on your skin even inside you don't
reach for the panic button just yet
although you have 10 times more
bacterial cells inside you then your
body has human cells many of these
bacteria are harmless or even beneficial
helping digestion and immunity but there
are a few bad apples that can cause
harmful infections from minor
inconveniences to deadly epidemics
fortunately there are amazing medicines
designed to fight bacterial infections
synthesized from chemicals or occurring
naturally in things like mold these
antibiotics kill or neutralize bacteria
by interrupting cell wall synthesis or
interfering with vital processes like
protein synthesis all while leaving
human cells unharmed the deployment of
antibiotics over the course of the 20th
century has rendered many previously
dangerous diseases easily treatable but
today more and more of our antibiotics
are becoming less effective did
something go wrong to make them stop
working the problem is not with the
antibiotics but the bacteria they were
made to fight and the reason lies in
Darwin's theory of natural selection
just like any other organisms individual
bacteria can undergo random mutations
many of these mutations are harmful or
useless but every now and then one comes
along that gives its organism an edge in
survival and for a bacterium a mutation
making it resistant to a certain
antibiotic gives quite the edge as the
non resistant bacteria are killed off
which happens especially quickly in
antibiotic rich environments like
hospitals there is more room and
resources for their resistant ones to
thrive passing along only the mutated
genes that help them do so
reproduction isn't the only way to do
this some can release their DNA upon
death to be picked up by other bacteria
while others use a method called
conjugation connecting through pi light
to share their genes over time the
resistant genes proliferate creating
entire strains of resistant super
bacteria
so how much time do we have before these
superbugs take over well in some
bacteria it's already happened for
instance some strands of Staphylococcus
aureus which causes everything from skin
infections to pneumonia and sepsis have
developed into mr sa becoming resistant
to beta-lactam antibiotics like
penicillin methicillin and oxacillin
thanks to a gene that replaces the
protein beta lactams normally target and
bind to mrs a can keep making its cell
walls unimpeded other super bacteria
like salmonella even sometimes produce
enzymes like beta levels that break down
antibiotic attackers before they can do
any damage and e-coli
a diverse group of bacteria that
contains strains that cause diarrhea and
kidney failure can prevent the function
of antibiotics like quinolones by
actively booting any invaders that
manage to enter the cell but there is
good news scientists are working to stay
one step ahead of the bacteria and
although development of new antibiotics
has slowed in recent years the World
Health Organization has made it a
priority to develop novel treatments
other scientists are investigating
alternate solutions such as phage
therapy or using vaccines to prevent
infections most importantly curbing the
excessive and unnecessary use of
antibiotics such as for minor infections
that can resolve on their own as well as
changing medical practice to prevent
hospital infections can have a major
impact by keeping more non resistant
bacteria alive as competition for
resistant strains in the war against
super bacteria de-escalation may
sometimes work better than an
evolutionary arms race
[Music]